auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge
[Musik]
mit der fall gekommen
kühne pläne cornelia breit schmiede und
schon marie suter wurden in marokko eine
kleine feriensiedlung bauen
neues leben neues glück die familie
händler übernimmt den schwedisch
lappland eine hotel und campinganlage
und auf und davon in ein neues abenteuer
mit kamelen zieht die familie blum durch
das australische outback
[Musik]
minus 15 grad in schwedisch lappland
kaum angekommen und den motor abgestellt
ist max henzlers katze abgehauen jetzt
muss hilfe her
meine katze ist abgehauen können sie von
der feuerwehr mir helfen sie vom baum
herunter zu holen
sid
er hatte viele chefs sind für bildungs
gerüstet ich habe der rostocker mit der
das war allen klar
in der letzten folge von auf und davon
familie blum aus davos hat erneut die
abenteuerlust gepackt
weder kamel noch gastgeber niemand da in
australien
im aargau nicole marischka abschied von
seinen acht kindern
herzlicher empfang für ihn und seine
frau cornelia in marokko
nach einem burnout wagt max mit seiner
familie eine neu anfangen in schweden
das ist richtig stark
20 minuten später ist sie da die
feuerwehr über zwei stunden sitzt er nun
schon auf dem baum
auch der verkäufer der ferienanlage ist
bereits auf den beinen
was wir nach fliegender start
24 stunden ohne schlaf und
1400 kilometer autofahrt in den knochen
seine jedoch holt max selber vom baum
ein bisschen mehr nach rechts
das kurz kurz alles gut bis jetzt
[Musik]
wärme und schutz bietet eines der freien
ferienhäuschen
[Musik]
man werden
auf dem kamelhof in horka war die nacht
kurz erst spät abends konnte die familie
blumen ihre gastgeber begrüßen
kaum ist die kleine nayla aufgestanden
erwartet sie schon das erste abenteuer
kakadu
nur töchterchen amira fehlt
mir ist es ein bisschen übel
ist hier immer noch schlecht am morgen
auch kennen die besitzerin des hofes ist
besorgt dabei ist heute ein großer tag
heute sehen die blumes zum ersten mal
ihre wilden kamelen
[Musik]
wie siehst du blickst naja
ich hab ich meine
sich und die familie heißt ihr lied
denn
zum lauf nicht immer alles klar so wie
es halt selber blauen zu den mächtigen
das ist
fünf autominuten vom hof entfernt
bis vor wenigen tagen lebten diese
kamele wild in der australischen steppe
die kamel dame eva ist bereits gezähmt
und hatte eine wichtige stellung inne
sie ist vorbild für die noch
ungewöhnlichsten neuankömmlinge
wegen ihrer zähigkeit brachten die
engländer einst kamele auf den fremden
kontinent und setzen sie als lasttiere
beim bau der eisenbahnlinie nein
als die tiere ihren job erledigt hatten
ließ man sie einfach in der wildnis
zurück nur wer diese kamele selber
trainiert lernt die tiere wirklich
kennen
das füttern von vertrauen schaffen
sie sind also ruhig komplett zu
und die sind so einfach sagen ist mir
vorgestellt habe besser
tut einfach so aus würde ich zitiere
nicht interessieren
ohne das sie
[Musik]
trennen
die taktik geht auf denn wer futter
bringt kann kein feind sein
[Musik]
während der ersten monate wohnen die
marokko auswanderer in einem außenbezirk
von isra
die wohnung hat ihnen der deutsche die
deal vermittelt
[Musik]
einfach nicht mehr druck fahrer wenn
meine
eisplatten
jetzt gern mal zum arzt
nötig sind so position sieht
elektro und bleiben wenn man nach dem
arztbesuch musik marco kopieren und so
[Musik]
was geht natur und ich auf die schnelle
schubert weiter mit
[Musik]
die aufenthaltsbewilligung müssen sich
cornelia breitschmid und jean-marie
suter als erstes beschaffen
[Musik]
er ist ein land mit einem riesigen
verwaltungsapparat und einer
schwerfälligen bürokratie das braucht
nerven und ausdauer
fladenbrot und
[Musik]
kollege didier ist schon seit jahren im
land er weiß wir sind den marokkanischen
amtsstuben zu und her geht daraus hat er
ein geschäftsmodell entwickelt er hilft
ausländern im land fuß zu fassen
jo marie ist im internet auf didier
gestoßen
hinter nächstes im workshop weiß genau
wie das land
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im norden schwedens hat max hetzler nur
wenig geschlafen
[Musik]
mit schlafen jetzt richtung geht ist
okay
max frau und die buben sind noch
unterwegs unterwegs ins neue heim
in over tokyo haben die henzlers ein
hotel mit restaurant und einem dutzend
ferienhäuschen gekauft
[Musik]
die anlage liegt direkt am tor näher
fluss
wohnen wird die familie künftig im
haupthaus der anlagen
heute findet die übergabe statt das team
ist eben fertig mit reinigen
vor zwei monaten hatte max die anlage
das erste und einzige mal besichtigt
nach 20 minuten wusste er hier will er
mit frau und kindern ein neues leben
beginnen
si
[Applaus]
marcus loew land kommt zur übergabe er
ist der vorbesitzer zusammen mit seinem
bruder hakan
haben sie dort oben auch geputzt willst
du hochklettern ich hätte eine leiter
die holen könnte
ich mache es mal so wie meine kinder
aber die sind einiges jünger als ich
es ist
ja
das 10
[Gelächter]
nix ist soweit zufrieden
eine mini-tour fragen stellen wenn es
nicht versteht oder nicht rauskommt oder
den bereichen aufhängen
das neue lieben die kind mit einräumen
bis tief in die nacht tragen die männer
die kisten ins neue zuhause
[Musik]
in marokko machen sich die auswanderer
auf ihre pendenzen liste abzuarbeiten
dank dieses verbindungen haben sie
mühelos einen arzttermin im spital
begonnen
die klinik befindet sich im zentrum der
hafenstadt izmir
meine songs landgard dann muss man sich
nicht an dieser stelle
[Musik]
knapp eine stunde später haben sie ihre
bescheinigungen
physisch in ordnung dass wir so eine
aufenthaltsbewilligung
das paar worte mit dem arzt und
durch das ausfüllen und hört sich gut an
das papier seien
gesund und stubenrein
doch vertrauen die auswanderer dem
marokkanischen gesundheitssystem
das ist richtig gemacht aber dann das
sehr akut werde und so werde repatriiert
egal ob als thema aber der wein nicht
auswanderer in island
dann doch nicht mich fragen
und nehmen in anspruch was sie da bietet
didier hat nicht nur verbindungen zum
spital er kennt auch den angeblich
besten kopierer der stadt
[Applaus]
seit 13 jahren lebt die dir hier und in
dieser zeit hat er drücke die lokalen
gepflogenheiten angenommen
aber der regie mit fred
zufrieden bedeutet wohl meistens mehr
als genug nun
berate ich nicht
ich habe schweigen blick
halle schnell war
[Musik]
amiras übelkeit ist verflogen und auch
sie ist bereit für neue abenteuer
[Musik]
die blumenkinder haben glück schule und
kindergarten liegen nur fünf gehminuten
vom kamelhof entfernt
[Musik]
hoffe dass es einfach
vorgestellt und damit
sind wir immer gut geschlagen hat dann
kamen
die rocker area school ist eine
tagesschule
guten morgen sind sie die schulleiterin
sabrina weiß was es heißt an einem
fremden ort zur schule zu gehen
als kind hatte sie fünf jahre in
australien gelebt amira und neuerer
werden kaum schwierigkeiten haben die
lehrerin oder ihrer mitschüler zu
verstehen
schon früh hat ihnen die mama märchen
auf englisch vorgelesen
[Musik]
die marokko auswanderers hin zufrieden
schon bald sollten sie ihre
aufenthaltsbewilligung bekommen
im hinterland von esra liegt das
grundstück welches cornelia und chambéry
erwerben wollen die gegend ist bekannt
für seine adern bäume die nur in dieser
region wachsen
gemäss
e-mails die folgen
[Musik]
auch die architektin ist da madame klima
sie einfach die ersten pläne für die
feriensiedlung der beiden
so ist im glück
weil er mir wert mit einer stadt oder
auf dem land sind also das wird jetzt
eine vor der ersten aufgabe sie die
steintaler plante ich dass da hat der
mut und das höchstniveau wir dann wohne
tk kinder ist alles werkstatt
landwirtschaft der sonne eigentlich ist
voll da weg sind dann alle gäste höflich
und autos mit mit mit rezeption mit dem
rechten rand und und mit dem
swimmingpool und einfach davon ist die
ganze
wohnbereich
den großen respekt
für mich ist aber bis neues also viel
ist auch sind also vom bau war nicht
wirklich einig aber noch keine
betrieb und mit angestellte schafft und
so vertrauen in die technik also
die ernte des ehepaars uta nicht salz
steine steine aber
es gibt schon oliven
die brauchen noch einen oder zwei monate
noch hat das ganze einen haken noch
gehört ihnen das grundstück nicht ohne
baubewilligung können sie das land gar
nicht erwerben und die bewilligung die
steckt irgendwo in einer an stube fest
noch nimmt es die ehemalige leiterin des
sozialdienstes gelassen
zu meinem
aber jetzt komplett des zu institute
geplatzt
so nervös war max wohl schon lange nicht
mehr
[Musik]
für jasmin ist es ein großer moment zum
aller ersten mal sieht sie ihr neues
zuhause
als max seinerzeit in kauf mit einem
handschlag besiegelte war sie mit den
kindern in der schweiz
verschiedene blattmacher anschauen
verstehen
und dadurch seinen truck is ja ja
ja ja überhaupt
richtig handelt sich ja so standard was
nowitzki ich hab
ja also ich habe sicherlich
willkommen
[Musik]
max und jasmin kauften einen laufenden
betrieb obwohl momentan nur wenige gäste
hier sind ist das restaurant geöffnet
[Musik]
koch jesper ist einer von zwei
angestellten die max übernommen hat
mit übernommen haben sie auch viel kram
und könnten
[Musik]
der vorbesitzer hat sich nicht die mühe
gemacht aufzuräumen das ist jetzt die
aufgabe von max und jasmin
ordnung in das puff zu bringen was man
ihnen geld
also
[Musik]
die blumenmädchen und sind in der schule
nun haben sabrina und markus zeit sich
den kamelen anzunähern
[Musik]
der
ziemlich
passend algerische zauns inkl
[Musik]
jetzt werden sie gefangen und dann gehts
wohl eine
alles halter kennt ja also ich nehme an
es wird ziemlich
ziemlich wild zu und her
[Musik]
markus erste große aufgabe auf dem weg
zum kamel flüsterer das ungezähmte tier
an einen pfosten zu binden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
leg das seil um den pfosten und zieht
das kamel zu dir hin
die blums geben sich sechs monate zeit
die tiere zu bändigen und zu schulen
dass mir das keiner und vorher können
wir nicht los weil die
friesen dafür für diese kinder und der
und das muss sitzen also vorher
also wie sich
kern weiß wie das aufgescheuchte tier zu
beruhigen ist
dezember entspannt
[Musik]
kaum ist die schule auskommen auch amira
und nahezu den kamelen
[Musik]
cornelia und jean-marie besuchen
gemeinsam mit die ihre architektin
[Musik]
madame krämer zeichnete die ersten pläne
für das zwei hektar großes landstück
und sie hat auch die baubewilligung für
die feriensiedlung eingereicht
kurz nachdem die auswanderer das
landstück entdeckt hatten unterschrieben
sie eine absichtserklärung für den kauf
des grundstücks eine kleine anzahlung
folgte und alles schien auf gutem weg zu
sein doch das ist eine weile her
es ist schon vier monate her dass wir
den vorverkaufs vertrag unterschrieben
haben ich möchte jetzt den kauf
abschließen wo stehen wir denn
eigentlich
ohne baubewilligung geht gar nichts
ja die baubewilligung es ist ja schon
eine weile her dass sie das baugesuch
eingereicht haben
ja schon aber die baukommission hat seit
vier monaten nicht mehr getagt
der
die blätter ist sie
ja das projekt muss bewilligt werden und
scharfkantig nummer
umsetzt weitergemacht werden wenn wir
die bewilligung hand und 4000 firmen ca
und sie liefert nach stücken
[Musik]
die architektin hat eine idee
bieten sie den grundstückbesitzer um
eine fristerstreckung
der besitzer des grundstücks würde das
nicht akzeptieren
die die kennt marokko er weiß jetzt
heißt es druck machen
was ich nicht will ist einfach warten
und nichts tun
die nächste idee die architektin schlägt
rudi schweizer sollen sich direkt mit
dem chef der provinz dem gouverneur von
sae ihrer treffen das sei ein offener
mensch er tanzte sogar auf facebook
ok madame wann denken sie dass wir eine
audienz beim gouverneur bekommen könnten
ich werde druck machen wenn gott will
schon sehr bald
ja da die schafe mit anderen megahertz
muss jetzt noch lernen
[Musik]
heute besichtigt jasmin die gesamte
ferienanlage und die ist riesig sie ist
mehrere fußballfelder groß
[Musik]
das ist verstimmt es erwarten jasmin ein
hotel 12 häuschen sogenannte stars und
40 stellplätze für wohnmobile
herzstück der anlage ist der
gemeinschaftsraum der campinggäste
[Musik]
schlecht graubereich des frieses
konferenzzimmer das geht sogar c jugend
ja auch gab das kann man so oder
so denn sind dritte
korb zu könig also yoga wird sicher
super dass laufform
das ist mir egal
hinzufügen
dem grund da müssen wir den mund
wenn tor gemacht
also dass gottes liebe ist das auch ihn
zurück ich auch du meine güte
mit gut aber nicht jede ist dubai ist
renoviert
später höchstens und lobte so
also die vorgebaute sind kaputt das
heißt das also war das erscheint ja
eingestellt werden
muss dahinter mit dafür die grüne tafel
rigbers also ich hab dort 80 sich jetzt
nach jetzt muss ott am rheinstrand
umso günstiger ist es sie also mit
günstiger bekommen
sie schaute sinkt sieht das muss nehmen
können
in der schweiz hätten sie für die
gleiche summe nur eine ein zimmer
wohnung in der vorstadt bekommen
während dreier monate wollen die blums
mit den kamelen durch das outback ziehen
durch das ist nicht nur groß das ist
riesig
mai juni juli main getrieben
die 21 kilometer buch
denken
realistisch
für die reise brauchen die abenteurer
neben gezähmten kamelen einen wüsten
tauglichen waren
ursprünglich wollte die familie auf
kamelen durch die wüste reiten
doch dann siegte die vernunft
wir sind gegen drei männer unterwegs und
kennt jeden tag auf dem ritt auf einem
kamel und wenn es einfach erkennbar mal
was machst du mal pause machen der muss
mit den banker salären
indien sorgen dass bürger oder machen
diese welt und es ist vieles ich denke
vieles einfach
beschäftigte mich nicht abschieds von
der straße gar nicht einfach im
salzgehalt abseits von straßen zu gut
wenn wir gar nicht auf asphalt
straße
im moment bewegen mit vielen dingen sehr
kräftig zu machen möchte einfach sich so
besonders
aber es ist doch
familien erleben ist dort im vordergrund
[Musik]
ein großes und unvergessliches
familienerlebnis soll ihre
abenteuerreise werden
amira und neujahr sind dabei immer das
wichtigste
nächste woche bei auf und davon drama am
frühen morgen
springmaus auto
und sabrina schießen lernen
erklärungen der architektin verunsichern
die marokko auswanderer komplett
noch mehr verwirrung stiftet der besuch
in kuba news sitz
in schweden liegen die nerven blank
[Musik]
ein fall für familienhund
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge